okay welcome back to Gary's Economics for this
the last video in this season of the channel
I'm gonna take a break
I'm going away for a couple of months
so I wanted to make a video
looking back over what has unambiguously been
the most mental season of Gary's Economics so far
okay
so what have we done this season on Gary's Economics
we've only been back about four months
in that time I think we have been one of the fastest
if not the fastest
growing YouTube channels in the entire country
we've successfully
pissed off a big chunk of the most annoying people
and newspapers in the entire country
we have effectively driven wealth
taxes and the idea that we need to tax wealth
not work
really aggressively into the public conversation
we started to achieve the things which
I've wanted to achieve for a long time and
that's basically thanks to you guys
last time I put the channel on pause was
last year we shot
I think at the beginning of July or the end of June
and it was just after the
general election had been called and
I was quite knackered then
probably not as knackered as I am now
but I got quite emotional in that video
I watched it back
and the reason I got emotional was because I said
in that video
it's I I worked really
hard last year
we had the channel running for most of the first
like 2/3 of the year
and then when the election got called it
the channel grew massively
but when the election got called
a little bit earlier than I was expecting
it was just really clear to me that
that we weren't gonna be able
I wasn't gonna be able to influence the election
it was really clear that Labour were gonna win
but it was really clear
we weren't gonna be able to influence their pitches
their policies
and I think I said at the time of the video
it's difficult when you've worked so hard
to look at how much work you've done
and how far you've come and
and then to look up and realise how much further
you have to go before you can have any power
before you can have any impact
and it was I was a little bit depressed to be honest
at the making that video
but now filming this 17th of April
this time we're putting the channel on pause
it looks realistically I'm not just saying this
it looks like something that eventually we
we could maybe win
the speed of the growth of this channel and this
this message
in this last season
the last four months has been just unbelievably big
it it was for periods
the fastest growing YouTube channel in the country
which it which is insane for a channel
which is essentially talking about about
redistribute politics and economics
every newspaper in the country been speaking about it
during this season we had the Spring Statement
which is kind of like a mini budget here in the UK
for those who don't know and
during the coverage of that budget
I think the single
most prominent
criticism of the government's economic policies
during that period
was why are you not taxing the rich more
you know that's not just us
and that's not just this channel that's
that's pushed that message
but I think a big part of it has been us and
I have said before on this channel and I've
I've thought for a while
I've been very confident for a long time
that the economy would get worse
because of this worsening wealth inequality
and that would move the
economic and political conversation
into a space where people demanded something
new and I was of the opinion for a long time
and I still probably am that the new
this new right this alt-right
the far right whatever you want to call them
the anti immigrant right
would eventually win power in a number of countries
really quite simply
because they were the only political
solution on the table
that felt like something new on the economy
and I believe for a long time
that if we can get this idea on
the table
that there is an alternative
which is taxing the rich more
taxing workers less taxing wealth
not work
that we could have a really good chance of winning
policy change in the long run
and for a long time it felt kind of unbelievable
kind of unachievable
because it just didn't seem like there was any demand
in the kind of
halls of power
it didn't seem like anybody was talking about it
it didn't seem like we could get it into the
overton window to use a term
I introduced a couple of videos
to get it onto the table basically and
it is just the first step and to some degree
it is only in this country
but we've got it onto the table
in the last four months
we have got that onto the table
and this is now something that politicians
have to talk about
it's something that politicians get asked all the time
it's something they have to have an idea about
we've obviously not won the Labour Party over yet
which are the party in government
we've not won the government over yet
but I never expected to win them
now I think I've said very clearly on the channel
my plan was to
make this something that we can
hopefully force Labour to do
coming to the next election
and the unbelievable growth in this channel
the unbelievable growth in this message in the last
four months makes me really for the first time in
in the history of doing this channel
makes me feel this is genuinely something
that we can achieve generally something that
that we can win and
that is something that I am very proud of
and it's something you can be very proud of
because ultimately this is a YouTube channel
it is increasingly a political movement
which bases entirely
its power on its popularity with the public
its popularity with you
its growth comes from people like you
telling your friends
telling your families telling your mum
like I always say
it's working you know
the reason that think tanks lobby
the politicians instead of speaking to the public
is because they don't think it works
they don't think you guys are powerful
they don't think you guys have power
they don't think there's any point talking to you
they don't think there's any point
basing movement on you and educating you and
and we are proving them wrong
and that's something we should all be very proud of
but basically I'm totally knackered
we used to shoot every three weeks
and we would try to shoot three or four
or maybe even five videos on a shoot day
and that was how we did it but
I've been so tired the last few weeks
that I have been unable to shoot more than one video
a shoot day
which has meant that I have to shoot every week
which means in the end
I probably am ending up doing more work
because I'm shooting every week
I think the quality of the videos
if I say so myself has been really
really good
well done also to Jack for his fantastic editing
I think the quality has been really good this season
but the flip side of that is it's just
really taken out of me and I'm quite knackered
which means we're not gonna be able to reshoot
we're shooting this on the Thursday
it's gonna go out on the Sunday
and it will be the last video of the season
and it'll be a couple of months break
but I'll be back so for now just quickly the recap
when I think back to this season
I always think the video I did with Aaron
Bastani at Novara
right at the beginning of this press campaign and
the first question he asked me was
were you surprised by how well the hardback did
so the hardback came out last year
and it was No. 1 for two weeks
and I always ask these guys not to send me the questions
before cause I like to sort of be
kind of actually answering them in the moment
rather than trying to like
remember my rehearsed answer
but I said to him
I was disappointed that the book didn't do better
because I thought
I thought the book got like
mischaracterized as a kind of a finance book
and I thought that it was actually a really good story
and I thought it had the capacity to do
to be much more than like No. 1 for two weeks
and maybe people thought that was quite arrogant
at the time but
it's been number one for 11 weeks and
I'll be honest I didn't expect it to do that much
and I think that kind of encapsulates
how I feel about this whole season
which was
the YouTube grew six times sub numbers last year
and I didn't think
we could possibly keep growing at that rate
but then we've grown
like two and a half times in the last three months
basically everything this season was way bigger than
I expected the book sold way better
the growth in the subscriber numbers and the views was
like dramatically more than I expected
the increase in like
public recognition that I get and like public sort of
critique and the increasing like
recognition on the streets has all been just like crazy
it has been absolutely crazy
for me personally
that is like amazing this was always
like the plan for the political project
but it's been quite a lot for me
personally and
it's been knackering
and I worry a little bit about how this channel
is gonna work for me
like long term from a mental health perspective
especially if it keeps growing and I think politically
you know if we wanna win
I need to to make the channel keep growing
but I need to find ways to make sure like
we find that balance where the channel is growing
but I'm not going insane basically
that brings me onto my next point
which I've got written down here
which is how can we win so obviously
I'm going away for a couple of months
and I want to talk a little bit about when I go away
I've taken breaks the last two years
this one will be a little bit shorter
there's always two reasons I go away
which is 1 to stop me from going insane and 2
because the channel has been going really quickly for
about two years now and every time the channel grows
I need to kind of take a step back
and reassess the situation politically and be like
what are we gonna need to be effective politically
in the next couple of years
the channel is much bigger now than it was even
3 or 4 months ago
so what are we gonna need now in order to win
so I think the first thing to say is
I think what
the last four months have proven is that the
the very basic strategy
has a lot of potential which is
I think there is
like a massive demand amongst the public for like
a very clear simple economic political message
which is
the reason we are getting poorer
is because of this massive growth in inequality
and we're not gonna fix that
unless we stop that inequality from growing
the inequality of wealth from growing
I think that is powerful for a number of reasons
one because it's true
I think that is the biggest thing, two
because it's simple, three
it doesn't like
muddy itself
by trying to deal with loads of issues at once
it just aggressively deals with this one issue
of worsening living standards and worsening inequality
so I think that course is running that can work
that will work and I would encourage
other people to look at that and say
you know
this is a message that that can win politically
the second thing is I think this
I think the slogan tax wealth not work
has a lot of has a lot of legs in it
you know I know
I don't really love condensing things into slogans
but the truth is you know
I think you do need to do that if you if you wanna win
so I think the first thing is like
I think this is a winning strategy
I think if enough people get behind this
if enough people support this
we can win power on this
and we can change policy on this
just a very clean
simple economic message
the reason living standards are falling
is because wealth inequality is growing
the rich are making enormously more money
the middle class
and working class are getting squeezed out
the only way to fix it is to stop growing inequality
to tax wealth not work
I honestly think that can win
but there are some clear weaknesses that I see
I think the obvious
like the really
really obvious weakness at the moment is that
at the moment this idea and these like
slogans is just like way too tied to my personal
like brand if you wanna call it that
like my like media identity
and you can see that in the way that
like the right wing press has
especially in the last like month or so
just like
really aggressively tried to attack me as a person
like they're not really engaging with the ideas
it's just like can we somehow attack Gary Stevenson
can we take him out
and that is because they can see that at the moment
the idea the economic ideas are really solid
but they are so attached to me as a person
that if you can take me out
you can kind of like kill the movement
so I think what that shows
us is that we absolutely need in the long run
more people doing it we need more diversity of voice
I think in particular
we need what I I'm thinking of as academic cover
which is economists people at think tanks
people with this kind of academic credentials
I have got two
economics degrees from two top universities
but because I am a Youtuber now
and because I look and sound working class
it's very
very important that we have these this academic cover
so I think we really
really need more support from these think tanks
especially the left wing think tanks
like the New Economics Foundation
like IPPR like the Resolution Foundation
they really need to be coming in and doing work on this
I would love to see more economists from from academia
writing papers on this speaking publicly on this
looking into things like the squeezing out of wealth
of the middle class where's the wealth going
you know what would the dynamics of that be
how does that affect living standards
we need more academic cover
but we don't need just academics
we just need way more diversity of voice in general
so one thing that I've seen
which I've really liked
it's been very meaningful to me personally is
is when like
different kinds of communicators and artists come in
so there was a clip of me on the
on the Rizzle Kicks album
Jordan Stevens who I know a little bit
they put me on the on the album
somebody sent us a cartoon
they'd be making based on the
the educational series learning the economy
which is on this channel
that stuff is really powerful as well
I think I would love to see more communicators
I think when we get loads and loads of messages
like tons of messages of people like
we love what you're doing
how can we help you can I come and work for you
how can we help and it's impossible really
for me to even read all these messages
never even reply to these messages
so what I wanna do is tell you don't come to me
just do it
just understand the messages and just do it
just go make the thing you know
this guy is making the cartoon making the music
you know
whatever you wanna do you wanna print stickers
you wanna make merch
I'm not gonna sue anybody for making any merch
using our name
or making any art using our ideas or make any music
like taking clips just go make it do the thing
I wanna see more influencers coming through
talking about these ideas
I wanna see economists talking about these ideas
I wanna see artists making art
I wanna see musicians making music you know
stickering campaigns, I would never
ever encourage anyone to do a graffiti campaign
or a stickering campaign or a posting campaign
just do the thing
do the thing that you wanna do that do the thing
use your skill
and if that means just like
make a little community group
talking to your community
and there's the thing which I always encourage just
just go and do it share the message
but when I say that
I always wanna caveat that with the thing I always say
which is this is not a thing we win today or tomorrow
or next week or next year
I don't wanna tell you like go out
do it go out and do it
go out and do it and then have you run out
exert a ton of energy exhaust yourself and then
be knackered and depressed that we haven't won
find a way to use your skills
or your community to build this message
over the long term in a way that's sustainable for you
and your mental health but
what we really need
what I really need is for this message
these ideas to not be so associated
with just
particularly me and my name and this YouTube channel so
you know
if you're a young person thinking about what to study
and you're willing to go study economics
go study economics
f you're an economist nowadays
go and write papers on these ideas and whatever
if you can get in the civil service
if you can get into government
if you can create something
if you can make a little group that wants to meet
and talk about these things
just basically build it build it yourself
go and do it
don't try and like pile everything up on top of my head
because
there's only so much
I can balance on my head before I go totally insane
that's another thing
the other big risk I think to
to this movement is is really my mental health
to be honest
I think anyone who's read my book
you know my book
is partially about you know
me experiencing a burnout
me overworking
I think there's a kind of like irony to the book
which is like the book was supposed to be in a way
like a criticism of modern culture which
which really lionizes like hard work and ambition
there's a quote by not Shakespeare
but a contemporary of Shakespeare
which is ambition is a great man's madness
and I wanted to try and sell a story of
of a way of living which was a bit more balanced
that we didn't have to be totally obsessed about
working hard and achieving um
and I locked myself
in my room for nine months to write a book
about that that was supposed to be a best seller
and now it is 11 weeks a best seller
and now I've got this massive YouTube channel
and I'm working my absolute tits off
driving myself mad
I need to find ways
if this is gonna keep growing and growing
and growing and growing it's gonna be difficult for me
and I need to figure out like
how I can manage that personally
on that note I wanted to really thank
everyone who's subscribed to the Patreon
like last year
we were funded by the Joseph Rowntree Foundation and
this year they they didn't renew our funding
which meant we came into this year
basically the only way that we could have funded it
was basically me paying for it
we open the Patreon and
the patron guys have you know
they basically made it that I can have a manager
none of the money ever goes to me
I didn't even see the money
there's a separate bank account
someone else managed it
and it means that I can totally focus on
all the creative work the political work
and I haven't had to focus on the financial work
so and also
it's just been really
just meaningful to me to see people like
willing to step in it and support it with
with their money
which makes it feel like it's not just me doing it um
and that means I can use
that money to think about things like
getting an assistant getting a PA
I think we are probably gonna need
somebody to do like outreach work
where they they can
I get tons of messages
so many messages from including like politicians
journalists celebrities
influencers people at these think thanks
and it's impossible for me to even keep on top of it
so we might be able to hire somebody to do that
and we're only able to do that
because of the guys who support the patreon
so I wanted to thank you specifically
everyone who's on the patreon
there are a few little loose ends
I wanna tie up before I go away
I plan to do another video before we stopped it
but like I'm just basically
I don't know if you've ever played the Sims
and I was like when you play the Sims
and you try to get your Sim to like
do some studying
and he's like so knackered that he just is like no
I refuse it
this is my own brain is doing to me at this point
like I'm I'm properly exhausted
but I wanted to do a couple of videos doing
covering just a couple of the
the common critiques that we've had in the last
like couple of months
and I'm not gonna do that video
so I'm just gonna include them very quickly
in this one
one of the big criticisms we've had is that um
raising tax on on wealth is like
is pulling up the ladder you're
you're preventing people from being able to get rich
now you are rich yourself
and this is just like totally insane
basically that
the whole thing I'm trying to do is
lower taxes on working people
and raise taxes on hoarded wealth
so that very very wealthy people have to sell assets
and those assets go back into the economy
and ordinary working people
get higher wages and pay lower taxes
and can afford to buy assets
like the whole thing I'm doing here
is trying to make it so that ordinary
working people
young working people who wanna produce good things
who wanna do good work can get rich and
and buy assets the other attack
which I get is that just like
I wanna increase taxes and
and increase the state
which is mad because I've always made it totally
totally clear that I'm not trying to increase taxes
I'm trying to change who pays taxes
I want to move the tax burden away from working people
and towards the super rich
and I think when you see how
like these attacks are constantly
attacks on things that I've never said
I think it kind of makes it clear
what is really happening here
which is you basically have a lot of rich people
who are just trying to find any way to
argue against the idea that they should pay more tax
it's a lot of rich people who control a lot of media
fund a lot of media they don't want to pay tax
the last thing was
this constant attack that I get which is well
taxing the rich is hard and
if you wanna tax the rich so much
can you please show me your like
completely designed tax plan
I think it should be clear at this point that I am
by far the the biggest and most recognized
public campaigner
for the need to stop growing inequality
and that there's quite a lot of pressure and work on
on just me to to push this campaign
I think we've had massive massive amount of success
but even just driving
the sort of public education campaign is really
really knackering for me and it's been a ton of work
it should be obvious
that I am not gonna be able to do that
and simultaneously by myself
design a complete tax plan for the country
and this is what I mean when I say we need more people
we need more people you know
I'm gonna call out like the think tanks
the left wing think tanks like where are you
we need you we need you guys to make these tax plans
I can't be the guy that wins the public
support for this
and gets attacked by the Daily Mail every day
and writes the whole plan
by myself like we need to have more people behind this
more people behind this
so if there's any economists watching this
people in government
people in civil service and people in the think tanks
help us draw up these detailed tax proposals
because I'm knackered and I can't do it by myself
we need help we need help
the last thing I've got here is
the personal attacks on me
I don't really like doing these lists
but I'm so knackered
this is kind of all I've got left really
loads and loads of personal attacks on me
which to be honest
often are the funniest part of my day
the one thing I wanna say about this is
you know I'm in a very
very fortunate situation here
I don't need to win this I'm a rich guy
if we lose I'll continue to be a rich guy
I'll get richer and richer
I don't need to win
so the Daily Mail can attack me all they want
when the Daily Mail attack me
what they're trying to do
is make sure that you pay higher taxes
and your family falls into poverty
and their billionaire owners don't have to pay tax
so really in a way
if the public can be convinced that I'm a dickhead
well I can finally go on holiday
it's your family's finances on the line
couple other things which I've got to tie up
we never answered
whether we’re gonna have Labour on the channel
thank you to everybody who
who replied about having Labour on the channel
I have decided first
I've been so knackered
I haven't really been able to seriously consider it
but I think what I'm gonna do is go back to them
and ask them if they would be willing to speak to me
not on the channel
about the economy and about their policy
because I think it has to be clear
I think our best chance in this country at least of
making change is is to influence the labour body
I think they will be
because the economy will continue to worsen
I think they will be like really phenomenally unpopular
and they will continue to become more unpopular
as we approach the next election
they'll be forced to do some change
and I want us to be able to influence that change
basically so I want
I want to be able to influence them
I don't think having them on this channel helps because
you know if I get them to send
you know Torsten Bell or someone on this channel
to defend not taxing the rich
and I have a massive argument with
you know somebody who could be the next Labour leader
for all I know I don't think that helps us get
we’d probably get views on here especially
you know we’d probably get some
some subscribers
but I don't think it helps our political power
just like having a massive public fight with the exact
people that we need to influence
I'm gonna try to see if they're interested
interested in talking to me about policy
and if they're not then I'm probably not interested
in having them on the channel
second thing
very little one is as the channel is growing a lot
there's been a massive growth in scammers
trying to convince people to join
like online
WhatsApp groups and stuff
trying to sell like like crypto and trading scams
I would never do that if anybody approaches you
it's a scam
when this first came up
we would try to get these guys taken down
but like all it means
I spent 20 minutes getting a channel taken down
and they just open 10 more channels
so there's really nothing I can do
you can complain to Instagram if you want but
just don't give any scammers your money
we don't sell any trading tips
and we never will okay
that's it basically yeah
lastly just yeah
thank you for just
the unbelievable growth it's
it's hard for me personally sometimes
as I've been
someone who has been betting on a weakening economy
for 14 years now and
and I'm very very confident that I'm right on this
I've made a lot of money on it
I think it's gonna keep happening
and the truth is in my heart of hearts
I've never really believed
that we could do anything to stop it
there is a little scene towards the end of my book
where when I used to be a trader
I'm speaking to my junior
an Australian guy in the book is called Arthur Kapowski
where I said to him like
do you think we should try and do something
about the collapsing economy
and he just didn't understand
and he just sort of laughed and he was like
you know there's nothing you can do
there's no way you can stop it and
the truth is like when I quit banking
I think in my heart of hearts
I believe that he was probably right
that it was kind of a fools errand that I was doing
walking away from a lot of money
to try to stop a bad thing from happening
which in reality
I would probably never be powerful enough to
to stop or even influence stopping
and I probably really did believe that
until up to about a year ago
but don't believe that anymore
I think we can maybe do this so
so let's keep building let's keep building
I wanted to there was another video that I wanted to do
which I've too knackered to do
which I'm gonna just tie in to the ending of this
I wanted to do a video this is so random
I wanted to do a video talking about the
the Spanish conquest of the Aztec Empire
and the reason I wanted to do that video is because
a lot of people don't know this
but the Aztec empire
which was in what is now Mexico
was a massive empire with
they think something like 12, 13
14 million people and the group of Spanish people
who eventually conquered the entire Aztec empire
was less than 3,000 people
and how was it that 3,000 people were able
to conquer and and destroy and
take all of the wealth and the land of an empire
which was you know more than 10 million people
what they did was they landed
they worked out the kind of political groupings
and they allied with the larger group
and they used that group to destroy the smaller group
and then
they split the larger group into smaller groups and
and they did the same thing again
they use the larger group to split into smaller groups
and through that repeated plan
3,000 people were able
to totally dominate and take all of the wealth
and all of the land of an empire of
you know 13 14
15 million people and
more than 10 million Aztecs died
at the hands of just
3,000 people.  This is what can happen
if ordinary people in society
allow themselves to be driven against each other
and to hate one another
that can allow a tiny tiny
tiny group of people to to take all of your wealth
to take all of your assets
and to totally destroy your civilization
and your quality of life
and everything that you care about
this is the direction that
that we can go in
if ordinary people are unwilling or unable to
you know
look to the people that live either side of them
and stand with them to protect themselves from
from the rich and the powerful
and for a long time I thought that
in our increasingly individualistic society
because ordinary people were not sort of willing or not
not able to to look past their very narrow
selfish interests and stand next to each other
that they would lose
but the last few months
but I've seen so many people across the country
willing to take time out of their day
take effort to try and support a movement
that they don't gain anything from personally
because they know it's what the society needs
to protect each other
have made me believe that maybe
maybe we can win this
maybe we can stop wealth
flooding away from ordinary families
towards the rich
maybe we we can get that back and maybe we can win
but it's not going to be just me who wins it
and it's not going to depend really on me or what I do
it's going to depend
on you and how many of you
are willing and able
to spread that message and
I'm going away for a couple of months
I'm gonna be
yeah in Japan
Italy Portugal
Sweden and mainly promote my book
but when I come back
I wanna see more people making cool things
if they're gonna grind down
the ordinary people of this country
I want to
at least see you make some cool stuff on the way down
that's what's gonna help us win
you guys ordinary people
getting behind the simple idea that
if you don't stop growing wealth inequality
it will destroy living standards for ordinary families
for your kids and your grandkids
I've said it before I'll say it again
we're not gonna win this today
we're not gonna win this tomorrow
so um
be calm
be patient
be there for each other
God knows you're gonna need each other
but keep building, if you keep building
we can win this good luck